hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and we're going to see
what happens when we put a five pound
gummy bear in a blacksmithing Forge for
science look what came in the mail huh
shall we open this up here alright let's
do it
oh my goodness oh look at that
I love the LOB here me and my stomach oh
wow yeah heavy that is oh look at that a
five pound gummy bear King ah god this
gummy bear is water on my head
this larger than your head yeah oh you
can you can have a bite you can each
bite in here alright let's go test this
sucker up
all right so we've got my blacksmithing
porridge here which I can get hot enough
to melt steel and we're gonna put this
five pound cherry gummy bear in there
and see what happened so tell them what
do you think is going to happen
Namie mini will be black there will okay
here's crusted get black and crunchy
go forth turn it on buddy
[Music]
interrogation doesn't work on
do you think we should melt it to the
ground
[Music]
Nathan should we put it in the Forge huh
all right let's do it
Nathan are you eating too gummy bear
yeah Yuri the gummy bear
[Applause]
so sabi Jodie's a gummy bear all right
we got to get this thing in the Forge
before it disappears
[Music]
oh that's crazy-looking
this is how they bury dead I gummy bears
[Music]
oh yes
oh I get it
ah
[Music]
higher
it's getting all over my board
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right for the first like
five ten minutes on the forge the gummy
bear actually smelled pretty good it
smelled like baking ooh
cherry kool-aid or something but it
starting to smell like burnt sugar
if you've ever burned a marshmallow
making s'mores like that times 10 he
tell me what is his millage nothing nice
an owl that wanted school oh all right
let's check this out do a scary and now
it's crunchy and yummy ha ha ha I don't
know it doesn't look very yummy to me it
looks a while they're yummy my dad looks
a little bit yummy do you think it looks
a little bit yummy wow you want to eat
some of it yeah so Tommy you think this
looks yummy
yeah you want to eat some yeah you sure
well ok let me try this little bit here
hot you put up your hip you don't try it
here take it off here take it off with
your head no lots more like iam sauce
monster mouth like a soft marshmallow
yeah
[Music]
you know what it actually does pretty
good it tastes like up cherry flavored
s'more here it got a nice smoky flavor
some on my finger thanks cannot hear out
that bad this pieces of charcoal in it
but that's like ok actually I just have
a crunch to it sound bad this is like a
roasted marshmallows huh plenty rate
thanks for watching this video we hope
you had fun the outdoor boys YouTube
channel puts out new videos every week
so don't forget to subscribe
noted nailed it hey Maury I'm here
mm-hmm I would like you to try any more
rest in peace gummy bear